قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
عمليات بلاده العسكريه في شمال سوريا
والعراق لم تقتصر على الغارات الجويه وان
نقاشات ستجرى بشان اشراق قوه بريه فيها كم
انتقد اردوغان دعم واشنطن من سماهم
الارهابيين في سوريا
تصريحات اردوغان تتزامن مع تبادل للقصف
بين القوات التركيه وحزب العمال
الكردستانيه او قاعه قتلى وجرحى على
الجانبين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذلك خبر
سوريا وما الحدود التي يمكن ان يبلغها
التصعيد الراهن بين انقره وحزب العمال
الكردستاني
ومره سائل التي اراد اردوغان توجيهها
لواشنطن بالتعبير عن امتعاد انقره من
استمرار الدعم الامريكي لمن سماهم
الارهابيين في شمال سوريا وكيف سيتم
استقبالها
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان ترد الحكومه السوريه
والعراقيه على الضربات ضد حزب العمال
وحلفاء على ارضهما وما فرص واحتواء تصيد
الحلي في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
بموازات قصف بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره
تشمه ايران على مقر احزاب كرديه ايرانيه
معارضه شماليه العراق قال الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان ان العمليات العسكريه
التي تنفيذها بلاده ضد حزب العمال
الكردستاني
سوريا والعراق لن تقتصر على الغارات
الجويه
في العمليه
واشار الى ان المهمه تتلخص في القضاء على
المنظمات الارهابيه
الرئيس التركي اشار ايضا الى ان روسيا لم
تلتزم باتفاق سوتشي بشان تطير المنطقه من
الارهابيين
وان تركيا سبق لها ان اكدت انها لن تصمت
اذا ذلك وهو ما حدث بالفعل بحسب قوله
اضاف اردوغان ان تركيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تنضويان تحتوي ظله النيته لكن
واشنطن ارسلت رغم ذلك الاف الاليه
والاسلحه الى ما سماها منطقه الارهاب في
سوريا
واشار الرئيس تركيا
من ارسالها اسلحه الى ارهابيين في سوريا
منذ عهد اوباما لكن الادارات الامريكيه
اللاحقه استمرت في هذا المسلك وفق قوله
تصريحات اردوغان تتزامن ايضا مع قصف
متبادل بين القوات التركيه وحزب العمال
الكردستانيه اسقط قتلى وجرحى بعد يوم من
اطلاق تركيا عمليه عسكريه تحت اسم المخلب
السيف ردا على تفجير الذي ضرب اسطنبول قبل
نحوي اسبوع
على مناطق ماهوله في تركيا
كما جرح سته وهم يتلقون العلاج حاليا في
المستشفيات نؤكد ان العمليه العسكريه التي
بدات بالامس وسببت الكثير من الخسائر
للمنظمه الارهابيه ستستمر داخل تركيا
وخارجها وسنعطي الجواب المناسب وسنقوم بما
يجب القيام به
[موسيقى]
لملخصات هذا الموضوع معنا من اسطنبول
الدكتور سعيد الحاج الباحث في شان التركيه
والعلاقات الدوليه ومن واشنطن الدكتور
خليل العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث بالمركز العربي
في واشنطن نبدا معك الدكتور سعيد الحاج هل
يمكن فعلا لتركيا انتشن عمليه بريه في
شمال سوريا ضد حزب العمال الكردستاني كما
توعد الرئيس اردوغان
مساء الخير تحياتي
بالنظر للدوافع والناحيه نظريه بحته اعتقد
ان العمليه البريه التركيه التي تلوح بها
في سوريا حتميه لكن الواقع العملي قد لا
يكون ذلك تماما بمعنى انه من منظور
استراتيجي تركيا ما زالت تنظر انه عمليات
مكافحه لموحدات الحمايه او العمال
الكردستاني في كل العراق وسوريا لم تؤتي
ثمارها لم تصل لنهايتها بعد على مستوى منع
انشاء كيان سياسي على حدود الجنوبيه وايضا
حتى على مستوى ان شاء الله منطقه امنه في
الشمال سوريا وبنظور سياق حتى ما يتعلق
بتفجير اسطنبول عمليه النخله بالنصر
الجويه كان يفترض بها ان تكون رساله ردع
ورد على هذه العمليه الان قصف العمال
الكردستاني او المجموعات السوريه
المتعاونه معه في الشمال السوري واسقاقات
شهداء في الداخل في المدن التركيه هذا
يستوجب ردا اقوى انجاز التعبير بالتاكيد
الخيار الجوي موجود لكن ليس هناك ضمانات
بان يكون هو صاحب الكلمه الاخيره وان يمنع
قصف مستمر من العمال الكردستاني ولذلك قد
يكون فكره المنع تماما لاي عمليه او اي
قصف من الارا سوريا نحو الاراضي التركيه
مرتبطه فعلا بعمليه ولذلك يشبه حتميه من
هذا المنظور لكن عمليه كما في العمليات
التركيه السابقه في شمال سوريا تركيا
تحاول دائما الحديث مع الدول الفاعله وفي
مقدمتها روسيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ودرجه اقل ايران في محاوله لان
تكون دائما عملياتها دون اعاقات دون
عقابات بحيث يكون مدتها بكلتها خسارها اقل
وحتى اللحظه لا يبدو ان كل من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا قد تخليها عن
الخط الاحمر الذي وضعته امام اي عمليه
عسكريه تركيه وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه
التلويح الان مرتبط بالسياق المرتبط
بتفجير اسطنبول لكن ما زالت تركيا في
محاوله لاستكمال التواصل الدبلوماسي انجاز
التعبير او السياسي وتحديدا مع روسيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم دكتور
العناني هل تتوقع لتركيا ان تنجح في تذليل
العقبات العقبات السياسيه هنا امام همم
شنها عمليه ذريه
تقوم القوات
التركيه بتقييم امكانيه حصولها في شمال
سوريا
موقف تركي واضح في هذه المساله وهناك
تصيرات حتى هذه اللحظه بين طرفين مهمينهم
الطرف الروسي والطرف الامريكي هناك كما
نعلم جميعا علاقات قويه جدا بين الطرفين
هناك يعني دور مهم جدا لتركيا في ما يتعلق
بحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فيما تعلق
بالعلاقات بين روسيا وبين اوروبا وبين
امريكا ايضا هناك علاقات تركيه امريكيه
قويه جدا وبالتالي اي تحرك تركي على الارض
لابد من وجود اخضر امريكا
من حاله الطلاع من الطرف التركي للطرف
الامريكي والروسي على اهميه القيام بعمليه
تركيا خاطفها وسريعه من اجل اولا رد همم
قوات
قصد قوات الديمقراطيه وكذلك حزب العمال
الكردستاني والرد بشكل قوي على تفجير
اسطنبول الاسبوع الماضي الامر الثاني ده
العمليه كانت مؤجله اكثر من سبعه او سته
شهور كان هناك حديث حول امكانيه قيام
تركيا
بعمليه بريه في الشمال السوري من اجل ض اا
وجود المنطقه الامنه على على مسافه 30 كم
اتفق عليها قبل حتى ثلاثه اعوام وبالتالي
هناك سداد تركي في هذه المساله هناك قد
يكون نوعا من نوع من التفهم من امريكا
لهذه المساله خاصه هناك التصنيف امريكي
للعمال كردستاني باعتباره منظمه ارهابيه
الدكتور سريع هذا الوقت نعم الموانع وفعلا
كان هذا الموضوع ايضا شيء بحتمي في فتره
معينه قبل اشهر وبات الحديث حينها عن
مواعيد محدده لهذه العمليه ولم تحصل نتيجه
الموانع السياسيه الان لماذا ستذلل هذه
العقبات مقابل ماذا ماذا ستقدم تركيا همم
ولماذا ستخلى الان واشنطن عن رفضها كذلك
روسيا
اولا من جانب تركيا هناك ذكاء تركي في هذه
المساله هناك اشعار تركي بان هناك رد فعل
يجب ان يتم اتخاذه لكن مبرر لهذه العمليه
الان هناك كانت ممنوع في الماضي لانه كان
هناك اعتقال هذه المساله الخاصه في ظل
الوضع المتهم في في اوكرانيا لكن الان
هناك مبرر تركيا يتم تقديمه على الاقل
الطرفين الروسي والامريكي بان هناك تفجير
ارهابي حدث في قلب اسطنبول في ميدان تقسيم
وهذا ما هذه ملتقى حيويه جدا وبالتالي
هناك حاجه للرد نمره واحد نمره 2 الظرف
الاقليمي والدولي وساعه التركيه في هذا
الاطار كما قلت قبل قليل هناك حاجه ماسه
جدا من جانب روسيا لتركيا في سواء فيما
يتعلق
بالمفاضات مع الغرب او مع اوكرانيا سواء
فيما يتعلق اتفاق الحبوب وفي نفس الوقت
هناك حاجه غربيه امريكيه اوروبيه تركيه
سواء ثم يتعلق به مساله حلف الناتو وعدم
مناعه التركيه في ضم دول اخرى كافرلندا
والسويد في النت وفي نفس الوقت هناك حاجه
الامريكيه التركيه باعتبرها وسيط في منطقه
وبالتالي قد يبدو الامر هذه المره مناسبه
لتركيا من اجل القيام بعمليه بريه في
الشمال السوري طيب همم سيد سعيد الحاج
عندما نتحدث عن عمليه بريه هل يقصد بها
دخول قوات تركيا
والبقاء في في شريط عند الحدود الشماليه
التركيه لفتره طويله ام عمليه بريه
للقيام بعمليه عسكريه ضد همم حزب العمال
الكردستانيه ثم العوده يعني هل هل الحديث
الان اذا اذا ما حصلت عمليه عسكريه البقاء
على الاراضي السوريه ضمن شريط محدد قطي-
قد يصل عمقه الى 30 كلم
نعم يعني اولا اضيفه ذاكره الدكتور علي
الدكتور خليل من التغير السياقات الدوليه
والاقليميه وتعلق بحرب اوكرانيا والموقف
التركي من السويدي في فنلندا من دوامهم
هناك سياق التفجير نفسه الذي استدعى تضامن
غير مسبوق لتركيا باعتباره استهدافا
لمنطقه تاريخيه وسياحيه واستهداف المدنيين
وايضا القصف المستمر حتى اللحظه ايضا
يستهدف مدنيين في مدن الجنوب التركيه هذا
دافع مختلف عن السابق والامر الثاني
السياق الداخلي التركي لا يحتمل ان تبقى
هذه عمليات القصف واستهداف المدنيين دون
رد حاسم يمكن ان يكون رابعا للعمال
الكردستاني وتم ظهورات السوريه ولذلك انا
اعتقد انه حتى سياقه داخل التركي يعطي
دافع عن فعلا لعمليه الان هنا الحديث
اعتقد هل ستقوم تركي بالعمليه بالتفاهم مع
الروس والامريكان ام رغبا عنهم وهل ستقوم
بعمليه موسعه ام محدود انا اعتقد ان
العمليه ستكون محدوده اذا ما اطلقات ستكون
اهدافها الاساسيه تل رفعت اولمبيج المناطق
الاقرب المناطق الاسهل البؤره التي تستهدف
حتى اللحظه السابقه ايضا الداخل التركي
وتسقط شهداء وتسقف التحتيه والمدن التركيه
والذي يمكن ان يستهدف او يعني يستحث رد
فعل روسي ربما حده الانجازات التعبير الان
هنا تحاول تركيا وانا اعتقد انه الان خلف
ابواب مغلقه هناك يعني نشاط دبلوماسي مكثف
بين انقره وموسكو من جهه وانقره ويشوت من
جهه اخرى ولكن اعتقد حتى لو لم تنجح تركيا
باقناع الطرفين بحقيه همم وعداله هذه
العمليه يمكن ان نكون امام نموذج عمليه
نبع السلام كما حصل في 2019 اطلقتها تركيا
في بدايتها رغم الرفض والتحفظ الروسي
والامريكي ثم لاحقا نسجت مع الطرفين
تفاهمات او وقفت في وجهها العمليه
للابقاء مقاتلي قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
بعيدا عن حدودها بعمق 30 كيلو متر والتي
ما زالت روسيا واشنطنطينيه
بها تماما ولذلك اعتقد ان تركي ان قامت
بهذه العمليه المناطق التي تحدثت عنها
ستبقى بها القوات التركيه مؤقتا ولا انت
انسحب منها لان انسحبها مره اخرى يعني
تسلل المسلحين مره اخرى اليها واستهداف
الاراضي والمواطنين
هنا ايضا همم ادري ان كان بالامكان الحديث
عنها وعن الدور الايراني ايضا في سوريا عن
رد فعل همم سوريا الدكتور خليل العناني
اود ان اسالك هنا اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن
ايران هل ترى نوعا من التناغم
التزامن بين
العمليات العسكريه التركيه وايضا
القصف الايراني في شمال العراق والهدف على
ما يبدوا بشكل عام يبدو كانه نفسه
لحد بعيد هناك تناغم تركي ايراني في هذا
الاطار طبعا الاسباب ودفع مختلفه من جانب
الايراني هناك قناع ايرانيه حتى هذه
اللحظه وجود دور مالي اكراد العراق خاصه
في منطقه يعني شمال العراق في كردستان
فيما يتعلق بالاضطرابات الداخليه في ايران
وهناك اتهامات واضحه جدا
لكردستان داخل كردستان فيما يتعلق بتاجيل
ال ال الغضب الداخلي في ايران واستغلال
ذلك من قبل ما تراهم طهران خصوم اقليميين
ودوليين فيما يتعلق بدعم تحدثوا عن دعم
سعودي دعم اسرائيل دعم امريكي في ما يتعلق
به الاحتجاجات الداخليه في ايران وبالتالي
هناك قصف وليس فقط بالامس او اليوم على
مدار اقل من اسبوعين هناك قصف ايراني
مستمر لمناطق داخل كردستان العراق القناعه
منها باعتبار انه هناك دور ما لدول
اقليميه واستخباراتيه لما يتعلق الوضع
الداخلي في ايران تركيا طبعا لا الهداف
مختلف لكن طبعا هناك هناك تنسيق بلا شك
بلا طرفين التركي والعالم في هذه المساله
هناك ما يبدو كعدوا طارق مش ترك على رغم
الاختلاف في حاله ايران هناك جماعات قد
تكون مش مرتبطه بشكل مؤخر بيعيوس بالاعمال
كوريستاني في حاله تركيا لا هناك حرب
مفتوحه بين تركيا وبين ماي كردستان مندو
على الاقل 30 عاما و هذه الحرب على كافه
الاسعدها سواء داخل العراق او سوريا دكتور
ايضا اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن الجانبين
التركي والايراني طيب اذا كانت الموانع
الامريكيه قد ذللت اوقدت ذلل مع الجانب
التركي وبالتالي الضوء اخضر لتحرك همم
لتحرك همم تركي في الشمال السوري هل يمكن
ان نقول ان هذا يعتبر ايضا نوع من ضوء
اخضر ضني لايران غير معلن ايضا للتحرك في
شمال العراق اذا كانت ال- ال- المبررات هي
نفس المبررات للطرفين باختصار
لا لا اعتقد ذلك هناك فرق كبير في الحسن
بين الحالتين الايرانيه والتركيه هناك
اتهامات ايرانيه واضعها بان امريكا خلف
الاضطرابات الداخليه وذلك من خلال دعم
جامعات معينه من خلال دعم يعني اشخاص
معيدين وبالتالي الوضع مختلف تماما لا
يعني على الاطلاق ان هناك ضربات ايرانيه
داخل العمق الكردستاني في في شمال العراق
ان هناك موافقه امريكيه هذا يعتبر الامر
غصبا عن امريكا العض الوضع مختلف مع تركيا
حاليا في تركيا حاليا في استراتيجي
لامريكا وبالتالي اي تحرك تركي سواء في
سوريا وفي العراق هو بشكل اوخر يعني ولكن
نوع من الموافقه الضنيه الامريكيه او
التفاهمات او تفاهمات امريكيه فتى الاطار
وبالتالي قال امين
كيف يمكن للولايات المتحده ان تبرر لتركيا
همم وفي نفس الوقت لا تبرر لايران اذا
كانت المساله متشابهه الى هذا الحد
هذا جزء رئيس من التناقض الامريكي تتحسن
في ما يتعلق بالعلاقه مع القوه الاقليميه
العلاقه الامريكيه الايرانيه علاقه متوتره
علاقه خصومه واعداء منذ 40 عمل على الاقل
وبالتالي من الصعب ان نضع الدوله
في نفس الكفه الميزان الدكتور سعيد الحاج
موقف
النظام السوري هنا اي رد فعل يمكن ان يكون
اضافه ايضا الى
هل هل ايران ايضا ستكون راضيه اذا التحرك
التركي في ما لو حصل بريا على شمال سوريا
ولا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تريد
عمليه عسكريه تركيه بريه في سوريا في شمال
سوريا هذا يعني تمددا اكبر للنفود التركي
وتمدد الاكبر للمعارضه السوريه القريبه من
تركيا وبالتالي هذا سيخصب من نفوذ الاطراف
الاخرى على مستوى المبدا ليس هناك رغبه او
اراده لكن على مستوى الميداني لنظام
السوري ولا المجموعات المحسوب على ايران
باعتقاده قادر على ايقاف او عرقله هذه
العمليه لكن الموقف الروسي الذي يتحكم
بالاجواء في سوريا الموقف الايراني
الامريكي الموجود عسكريه في شمال شرق
سوريا في شرق الفرات اعتقد انه يملك هذه
الامكانيه ولذلك دائما تركي بالمقام الاول
تتواصل مع روسيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهونا ثم تامر هناك في السياق
تفجير اسطنبول وما تبيعه من ارتدادات
وتطورات هناك تفهم روسي واضح انا اعتقد ان
القصف الجوي التركي لم يكن مكسوره فقط من
الاجده داخل الاجواء التركيه اعتقد ان
التركي استخدم هذه الاجواء السوريه وهذا
يعني ضوء اخضر روسيا الان السؤال هل هذا
الضوء الاخضر
لعمليه بريه قد تكون محدوده ام لا
انك تركت حدث مع روسيا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي هي الدعم الاساسي لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه ووحدات الحمايه تسليحا
وتدريبا وما الى ذلك ايضا غدد النظر في
خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه عن عده
عمليات استهداف وقصف تركيا في شرق الفرد
ضد مقار وشخصيات قياديه في قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه ليه علاقات التركيه الامريكيه
المتقدمه للسياق الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
للدوري التركي المتنامي وايضا ما تقدمه
تركيا من قرائن وادله على تورط اطياف في
هذه في هذه الوحدات ضد الامن القومي
التركي ولذلك اعتقد ان ما بعد تفجير
اسطنبول اعتقد انه يختلف كثيرا عن سياق ما
قبله ان تركيا تملك اوراق تفوضيه قويه هذه
سعيد سعيد تتفق مع سيد العناني بان اي
عمليه لم تحصل من دون اا من دون ضوء اخضر
امريكي واا روسي يعني كي لا يكون هناك
صعيد اكبر في المنطقه امين عام الامم
المتحده تعليقا
على العمليه العسكريه لتركيا يدعو لاقصى
درجات ضبط النفس وتجنب التصعيد الاقليمي
الى اي مستوى يمكن لعمليه عسكريه بريه ان
ترفع
هذا التصعيد الاقليمي وكيف ينعكس عموما
على امن المنطقه دكتور سعيد
تركي من حيث المبدا حريص على التفاهم مع
روسيا تحت الامريكيه حريص على ضوء اخضر
وعدم اعاقه على الاقل تقدير لكن كما ذكرت
في اجابه سابقه على احد الاسئله انا اعتقد
انه اذا لم تتوافق او لم تتفهم الدولتان
الدوافع التركيه قد تطلق تركي عملتها
البريه رغم الاعتراض الروسي والامريكي
وذلك سيدفع لمسار تفاضلي او حديث همم
دبلوماسي اخر بين الاطراف الثلاثه لكن
اكثر من ذلك وخصوصا اذا كانت العمليه
البريه كما نتوقعها محدود نوعا ما مخصصه
على الاقل في مرحله الاولى ضد منبج وترفعت
وبعض البؤر التي تستهدف داخل التركي انا
لا اعتقد انه سيكون لها تداعيات كبيره جدا
ربما سيتم همم الدعوه للقاء ثلاثي للاطار
استنى قمه وارضوان لقاء امريكي تركي في
محاوله للاحتواء الموقف لكن في نهايه
المطاف انا اعتقد ان دوافع التركيه
الداخليه والخارجيه تدفع بشكل باتجاه تحرك
ما ضد وحدات الحمايه السوريه الديمقراطيه
بما يمنع اي عمليات قصف واستهداف للداخل
التركي في المستقبل دكتور خليل العناني
بالسوري هنا
يعني الا يفترض ان يحسب له حساب ميدانيا
الا يعقد المساله هنا هل يمكن لي النظام
السوري ان يبقى ايضا ساكن ساكتا اذا عمليه
عسكريه تركيه من هذا النوع على اراضي شمال
سوريا
يعني بناء على سلوك نظام السوري خلال اخر
10 سنوات نعم ليس هناك امتعات سوري بشكل
او باقه طبعا علاقه تصريحات سوريه تدين
هذه الهجمات لكن بشكل او اواخر هناك نوع
من الاستسلام لهذا المنطق لانك منطق القوه
الذي يفرض نفسه قد راينا هذا الامر ليس
فقط فيما يتعلق بالعملات التركيه المتكرره
في شمال سوريا ايضا ضربات الاسرائيليه
المتوسطه ليس فقط يعني همم في الجولان
ولكن داخل العمق السوري هناك ضربات
اسرائيليه متصله سواء داخل مطار دمشق او
في مناطق اخرى فيما يتعلق بيقال انه اهداف
ايرانيه واهداف متعلقه بحزب الله وبالتالي
النظام السوري في حاله ضعف شديد ليس لديه
من الامر شيء لا يمكن ان يعترض على زي
العمليه حتى يعترض ان كل اعتراضته تاثير
بشكل او باخر وبالتالي همم العمليه
التركيه زي حدثت لن تاخذ في الاعتبار اي
موقف سوريه بل على العكس قد يكون هناك نوع
من فتره الدكتور سعيد وقلبي هناك تفهم
سوري هذه المساله خاصه همم قوات قصد على
جزء كبير من الشمال السوري وبيتكلم
كمصلاحها لنظام السوري في استعاده هذه
المناطق او باخر همم
دكتور سعيد باختصار هل هناك ضمان لان فعلا
تحقق اي عمليه بريه اهدافها خصوصا على
مستوى العمليات التي تصفها تركيا بانها
ارهابيه وتستهدفها في الداخل
يعني بالنظر الى الاسلحه الموجوده في ايدي
مسلحين قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وحدات
الحمايه فان تواجد القوات التركيه في هذه
المناطق الرفعت منبج وغيرها وابعادها
المسلحين الى عمق ابعد من 30 كلم عن
الحدود التركيه يعتبر بالتاكيد ضمانه لامن
الحدود التركيه وداخل الاراضي والمواطنين
الاتراك وهذا حصل في مناطق اخرى لكن في
هذه البؤر ما زال هناك امكانيه لهذه
المجموعات لان تستهدف تركيا في حال
استطاعت هذه العمليه ان تخرجهم من خارج
هذه المناطق ان اعتقد ان ذلك يشكل ضمانه
جزئيه بالطريقه طبيعه الحال لانه ما زالت
هناك قوات كبيره لهم في شرق الفرات محميه
بشكل او باخر بالغطاء الامريكي والمساند
الامريكي وهذا سيتطلب من تركيا لا حقا
استمرار الاستراتيجيه اما عمليات اضافيه
ميدانيه او تواصل اخر 24 لسحب غطائها هذه
المجموعه شكرا لك دكتور سعيد الحاج البحث
التركي والعلاقات الدوليه شكرا الدكتور
خليل العناني من واشنطن استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث
بالمركز العربي
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]